[Music]
on this Friday night one of Canada's
worst E coli outbreaks spawns legal
action the mounting outrage among
parents the kids you know they shouldn't
be having to go through this and what
one little girl is now enduring your
birthday like we can't do it anymore
because since you're going to be in the
hospital for the next month
the goal to eliminate the toxic culture
that's long poisoned Elite men's hockey
it's going to take time and the
criticism against how complaints are
investigated I wish I hadn't reported
and should it stay or should it Go the
push for a restoration instead of a
demolition at 24 Sussex Drive
good evening and thanks for joining us
Alberta's Pediatric Health System is
being pushed to the brink tonight
hospitals are dealing with one of the
biggest E coli outbreaks involving young
children in Canadian history so far
there are 142 lab confirmed cases and
that number is expected to grow as more
children who attended the affected
Calgary daycares could develop symptoms
26 children are being treated in
hospital and as Heather urac's West
reports some patients are now developing
a related and serious kidney and blood
disease
Kate Maxwell has never felt so lucky
four-year-old Farley attends one of the
Calgary daycares now associated with a
growing E coli outbreak so far he hasn't
been sick still Maxwell says she's angry
what was going on there and how dare you
how dare you put our children at risk
when we uh we trusted you while the
source of the outbreak is not officially
known the number of sick children is
increasing kids under five infected with
E coli are at an increased risk of
developing hemolytic uremic syndrome
two-year-old Amelia Leonard is now so
sick with hus she requires dialysis her
parents told to expect a lengthy
month-long Hospital stay hey kids you
know that shouldn't be having to go
through this they should be kind of
having fun and stuff especially with her
because it's like her birthday luck is
next week the anger amongst the families
impacted is palpable on Monday Alberta
Health Services declared an outbreak at
several City daycares all connected to a
Central Kitchen a Calgary Law Firm has
already filed a class action lawsuit on
behalf of the families we want to make
sure that these children's claims are
protected and that we can investigate
what happened here and get some answers
for these families the number of
patients diagnosed with hemolytic uremic
syndrome is expected to Peak over the
weekend but with so many sick the
Alberta Children's Hospital has had to
add capacity from the Pediatric
perspective I think this is as much or
more professional than we ever felt
during covid
um you know we have opened up multiple
clinics at multiple hospitals to offload
the emergency department as they work to
care for dozens and dozens of patients
who are both very sick and very young
Heather York's West Global News Calgary
it is day two of the conservative party
convention and members are getting fired
up 2500 delegates are meeting in Quebec
City behind closed doors to debate party
priorities the day narrowed down a pile
of 60 policy ideas to 30 proposals on
everything from defense to energy to
Health Care members will vote on them
tomorrow
all right
tonight Pierre pauliev took the
convention stage for the first time as
leader to Rally the Grassroots he's
riding the party's growing popularity in
Quebec as David Aiken reports the
conservatives are looking to make modest
but important gains there in the next
federal election
obviously when you when your name is
Pierre it's a good start Quebec City MP
Gerard deltel says his party's fortunes
are on the rise in his Province because
of Pierre pauliev and pauliev's nearly
single-minded focus on cost of living
and affordability after a full year of
leadership of people discover him the
Tories have just nine of the province's
78 seats and are aiming to boost that to
between 12 and 15 seats overall that may
be a small number but it could be the
difference between a majority or
minority government and so pauliev has
been busy courting Quebec in French the
conservative leader praised the party
cave Aqua Premier for example
for balancing budgets to save social
programs he said he'd do the same
pauliev said quebecers set an example
for all Canadians in defending their
Heritage quebecers and I'm saying this
deliberately in English do not apologize
for their culture their language and
their history they celebrate it and all
Canadians should do the same
the party is also featuring pauliev's
wife Anna in advertising and at party
events it is my pleasure
to share with you my husband expect more
of her the party thinks she's a
political asset but outside the
conservative convention the Liberals
dispatched two of their Montreal MPS one
of which argued pauliev is unqualified
to lead because of his views on climate
change someone who claims to be a
political leader in 2023 who does not
even believe in climate change who does
not believe that we should be doing
anything about climate change now
conservatives do indeed have a different
approach to climate change and the polls
showed that Canadians want every
political party to have a credible plan
on that issue but conservatives believe
as we just heard from their leader
Pierre poliev that a focus on
affordability and cost of living is the
clearest path to electoral success not
just in this province but in all of
Canada nifu all right David Aiken in
Quebec City thanks David
Global News has confirmed prime minister
Justin Trudeau will be meeting with
Indian Prime Minister Narendra Modi on
the sidelines of this weekend's G20
meetings climate change food security
and Russia's invasion of Ukraine are
expected to dominate The Talks this year
but as Toria Israel reports the Prime
Minister has hinted that foreign
interference will also be top of Mind
during his brief meeting with the leader
of the host nation
[Music]
prime minister Justin Trudeau has landed
in India and returned to a country where
he carries some baggage
[Music]
his last trip here was widely criticized
as disastrous good morning everyone
Trudeau is looking for a redo at the G20
Summit a gathering of the world's 20
biggest economies it's designed to be a
place where difficult but Frank
conversations are have he will have a
conversation with Indian Prime Minister
Narendra Modi a government Source
confirms the leaders will have a
10-minute pull aside the most informal
kind of meeting and less time than Modi
will have with Canada's allies like the
U.S and the UK the Trudeau messaging has
sort of rubbed the wrong way in India
um and I don't think there's much
personal chemistry they're they're
they're very different ideologically
modi's face is plastered all over Delhi
the Indian Prime Minister has shut down
the city telling Millions to stay home
businesses to close and tourists to
avoid the area this is sort of Mr modi's
moment in the sun on a broader scale
though I would say that the Jeep 20
Summit itself has a number of sort of
clouds hanging over it
India did not invite Ukrainian President
Vladimir zielinski and has taken a
neutral stance in the conflict unlike
Trudeau who insists Russia must be held
accountable for what he calls their
illegal War it's unclear if the conflict
will come up in their one-on-one but
Trudeau suggests he will bring up the
issue of foreign election interference
by countries like India on Thursday
Canada announced it's holding a public
inquiry into efforts to meddle into
Canadian democracy we will emphasize how
important the rule of law is the public
inquiry will focus largely on Russia and
China Chinese president Xi Jinping is
not coming to the G20 neither is Russian
President Vladimir Putin both are
sending representatives in their place
nithu tariya isri in Delhi thanks to Ria
Hockey Canada is grappling with its
history of misogyny and abuse as its new
leaders hold a summit in Calgary the
organization hasn't really turned a page
on last year's damning Revelations it
mishandled sexual assault complaints
despite demands from MPS the final
report investigating an alleged rape
involving 2018 junior team players has
yet to be released Mike drolets
after more than a year pitchton crisis
Calgary is where Hockey Canada has
re-entered the public sphere with a
singular Focus to change the narrative
surrounding the culture of the sport
Canada's a top hockey organization saw a
complete turnover of its leadership
roster with a new president and CEO
along with a new board of directors and
the new blood is very aware they have to
deliver tangible results you don't want
it the theme as just a you know a box
ticking exercise when we've done that
you know we had a conference to come out
with the principals we wanted to be
embedded we think that this has to be
part of everything that we do the hockey
crisis reached a fever pitch earlier
this year when Hockey Canada's leaders
were called to Ottawa to explain how
they had settled a lawsuit from a young
woman who said she was raped by several
members of the 2018 junior team
in the wake of the explosive testimony
sponsorship and funding money dried up
and a number of minor hockey
organizations stopped paying dues to
Hockey Canada for the first time
extraordinary motivation to change right
because of the funding cuts the
sponsorship Cuts I mean these this is
this is catastrophic some of that
funding putting right that's happened
with them so they have to respond
there's very strong motivation to change
the goal is to come up with a game plan
that will drown out what safe sport
Advocate Sheldon Kennedy calls
generations of systemic silence
that's just one of the hurdles he says
will take years to overcome I think it's
going to take time and I you know if I
look at my journey I mean you know
Sheldon Kennedy was in jail Sheldon
Kennedy was in mental health
institutions in seven treatment centers
and you know I was the laughing stock I
was the drunk I was the
and it takes work it takes work it takes
honesty uh it takes humility and above
all he says it takes a sincere
willingness to change microwave Global
News
last year Hockey Canada signed on with
the office of the sport Integrity
commissioner as part of their conditions
to regain their Federal funding that
office is responsible for handling
complaints made at the national level
for all other complaints to provincial
and Club level leagues Hockey Canada
contracts an independent third party to
investigate but some are highly critical
of this process David Baxter reports
I wish I hadn't gone through this
process I wish I hadn't reported this
woman who Global News granted anonymity
due to potential legal recourse had a
complaint investigated by Hockey
Canada's independent third party sport
complaints in 2020 just before the
pandemic she discovered a man she
alleges sexually assaulted her almost a
decade ago worked in the same hockey
league as her husband we didn't know
what we were going to do we almost left
the country to be able to ensure that my
family was protected
and then the ITP came along sport
complaints was a science of the file in
late 2022 the woman says she was
initially optimistic about the process
but that shifted as it progressed after
the initial investigation was complete
she brought her allegations to the
police in May with the criminal
investigation underway she said she was
asked to take part in an adjudication
session with the man she accused where
he'd be able to ask her questions
there's you know risk of contamination
of evidence that there's the likelihood
of him receiving evidence before he's
even been questioned by police the woman
requested the process be suspended while
the police investigation was in progress
the adjudicator denied this request in
an email response sport complaint says
that when there are simultaneous
criminal and complaint investigations
they work with police to ensure the
criminal side is not compromised adding
if police ask them to pause they will
shortly after the suspension request was
denied the woman formally withdrew her
ITP complaint the feedback we have had
is that the processes are dehumanizing
so lengthy that they are exhausting that
they are incredibly difficult to
navigate Kim Shore with gymnast for
change is critical of these complaint
processes saying victims often feel they
aren't getting Justice this is not a
sport issue this is a human rights issue
happening in sport sport complaints says
they change their policies in March 2023
based on feedback from those who have
taken part in their process stressing
they are trauma-informed and aimed to
resolve disputes in a fair manner but
for some there's a feeling let down the
only thing that we wanted at the very
start of this was for my husband to be
able to go to work
and not have a concern that he would
face the person that allegedly raped his
wife and they couldn't even give us that
David Baxter Global News
Ottawa
Canada's men's breakthrough run at the
basketball World Cup has sadly come to
an end Serbia handed Canada a decisive
95 to 86 loss today pushing the Eastern
European nation to its second finals in
the last three tournaments although a
championship is now out of the question
Canada will still have a chance to
meddle as they're set to play for bronze
against the United States on Sunday the
Americans lost to Germany in the other
semi-final game
torrential rain ravages two regions
coming up the flood waters wreaking
havoc on Greece and Hong Kong
in Mali Islamic militants have killed
dozens of people in multiple attacks in
the country's Northeast today a
coalition with ties to Al-Qaeda claimed
responsibility for a suicide bombing at
a military base near the GAO airport
mali's military Junta says a rocket
attack yesterday on a Riverboat near
Timbuktu killed 49 people Downstream in
Bamba insurgents attacked a military
Camp killing 15 soldiers a government
statement said 50 attackers were also
killed violence in Mali has increased
after two coups within the last three
years with military rulers ordering
French forces and U.N peacekeepers to
leave
a complex operation to rescue an
American caver stranded nearly 1 000
meters underground could start tomorrow
doctors say 40-year-old Mark Dickey has
recovered enough to be extracted he
became suddenly ill with stomach
bleeding during an expedition in
southern turkey Dickey has been treated
with IV fluids and four liters of blood
the rescue mission could last three or
four days as teams lift him out through
narrow openings on a stretcher
in Central Greece extreme rainfall and
flooding has left hundreds stranded and
at least 10 people dead
more than 1900 rescues have taken place
since the floods began to submerge
entire villages on Tuesday there are
fears more people could be found dead
when water levels begin to drop deaths
from the extreme weather have also been
reported in neighboring Bulgaria and
turkey
water gushed into the streets of Hong
Kong shutting down schools and
workplaces as the city was hit with its
heaviest rainfall in more than 140 years
about 158 millimeters of rain fell in
just one hour overnight causing
widespread flooding two people have died
and more than 140 have been injured
the future of 24 Sussex Drive ahead the
debate over what to do with the Aging
residents
24 Sussex Drive is one of the most
well-known buildings in this country
it's long been the traditional home of
Canada's Prime Ministers but Justin
Trudeau and his family haven't lived
there since he took office the residence
has been plagued by old age a serious
rodent problem and major security issues
and therein lies the great dilemma
restore it or level it Eric Sorensen
reports
the official residence hasn't been a
residence since Stephen Harper moved out
in 2015 and 24 Sussex needed restoration
long before that the prime minister's
Residence at 24 Sussex Drive has had no
major Renovations for 50 years make that
65 years now with asbestos old wiring
and plumbing and now rodents is it even
worth restoring for the Prime Minister a
group of Heritage Advocates business
people lawyers Architects are launching
an effort to do just that 24 Sussex is a
landmark and a touchstone with people
and events that have shaped our national
story it's the real thing with layers of
History intact originally built for a
lumber Baron at the time of
Confederation 24 Sussex became the prime
minister's residence starting with Louis
Saint Laurent in 1951. since then prime
ministers have hosted world leaders
first ministers conferences and raised
families here it is a part of Canada's
history but it is close to Sussex Drive
and highly visible perched on cliffs
above the Ottawa River the former Clerk
of the privy Council believes it is not
a secure location with the threats that
exist today my understanding is that it
would be extremely difficult to make a
residence on that site safe at anything
like a reasonable cost an architect
proposing restoration insists many
public buildings have been made safe in
Ottawa properties of much greater
exposure than 24 Sussex
to make them secure the national capital
commission found renovation would cost
almost 37 million dollars but it's
estimated a new residence that could be
built in nearby Rock Cliff Park would
cost 40 million Canadians have seen no
evidence that this new build would cost
a nickel
less than fix up in the end it may come
down not to cost but the need for the
highest possible security I respect the
Heritage and conservation argument but
I'm very sensitive to this you know the
issues around the safety of the Prime
Minister and the family Michael Warnick
says the history and the memories that
have been made at 24 Sussex can be made
for the next hundred years in a new home
the government says the decision could
come this fall Eric Sorensen Global News
[Music]
remembering Queen Elizabeth II next the
royal family marks one year since the
Monarch's death
today marks one year since the death of
Queen Elizabeth II in tribute King
Charles III shared a previously
unreleased photo of his mother taken at
Buckingham Palace in 1968. our Europe
bureau chief Crystal gomancing on how
the senior Royals and some members of
the public marked the day
a subdued crowd offering condolences to
King Charles III one year ago his life
changed dramatically he lost his mother
and took the throne in marking the first
anniversary of her late mattresses death
and my accession
we were called with great affection her
long life devoted service and all she
meant to so many of us I think his
majesty has done a tremendous job since
then Ed Wang is a Canadian Royal
commentator he flew to London last year
to be a part of the national period of
mourning it's so memorable seeing that
coffin and and being able to talk to
people in that queue about why they're
there and how they saw the late Queen
and how they saw the monarchy in the
afternoon it was announced the 96 year
old Queen was under medical supervision
at Balmoral Castle in Scotland by
evening her death was made public with a
royal notice posted at Buckingham Palace
the passing of Queen Elizabeth II was a
historic moment noted by people right
around the world and many say they
remember exactly where they were when
they heard the news
yeah no I of course I remember I was I
was in hotel but I work here and we were
actually having a really sad period I
was in Paris and um
I was in a taxi and on the radio it said
the London Bridge is down and I didn't
really get where he met at the time
until I got back home and then I saw on
the TV that
the the queen had died her life of
service was noted Thursday by Prince
Harry who was back in the UK attending a
charity event for sick children I don't
know exactly one year old
tonight
such an incredible community on Friday
The Prince and Princess of Wales
attended a private church service and
they also met with members of the public
reinforcing a line attributed to her
late Majesty we have to be seen to be
believed
Crystal gomancing Global News London
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm nitu garcha tonight
here Canada is this abandoned tractor
and Barn in Bend Saskatchewan thanks so
much for watching Farah Nasser will be
back at the anchor desk tomorrow have a
great weekend
[Music]
thank you